we know that many users feel that
finding content is too difficult in
typical Media Services over 50 percent
of the Gen Z audience canceled a
streaming service within the last six
months other reports indicate that 81 of
viewers are streaming services expect
highly personalized recommendations
Google is bringing the latest AI
technology to Media platform customers
to redefine the industry standard with
recommendations AI for media so in short
this product is all about making Media
Services sticky AKA strong retention
Stars was one of the first companies to
introduce recommendations AI into their
media platforms Stars saw a 40
Improvement in engagement rate and a 70
increase in completion ratio to get
started visit the discovery AI page on
cloud.google.com